we all love receiving gifts so do  children  however  some gifts could turn out to be very  dangerous take this toy guitar for  example  its strap has no quick release mechanism  if run around the neck  it could form a loop and trap your  child's neck  leading to strangulation  but  thanks to national authorities and the  european commission  this guitar was withdrawn from the  market  indeed  consumer authorities work together every  day to ensure that the gifts you choose  are safe  if this is not the case authorities can  ask the retailer to withdraw the product  from the market and another is  circulated on common european platform  the safety gate so that other member  states can also follow  since the beginning of this year  almost twenty percent of the alert  circulate on the safety gate rapid alert  system concern toys posing serious risks  to children enjoy giving with no worries  have a look at the au safety get website